That's it, that's it.
Okay, okay.
Hi!
Hello!
Welcome back!
Is your throat okay?
It's okay.
I think your throat is gone.
It's gone.
Were you screaming today?
Yes, yesterday, every day.
Every day.
Yeah, I understand.
Yes, yeah.
Okay, one more time.
Okay, okay.
Welcome back, master, teacher.
Shit, shit, shit, that again.
It's ASMR.
Mint.
It's me, I'm Mint.
This is my channel.
Okay, here we go.
Hi!
Welcome!
Not my channel, sorry.
Okay.
Do you want?
Yeah.
Oh yeah, thank you.
Please don't log out.
This is now Ayami channel.
Yeah, sorry.
Okay.
Hello, I'm 100 years old illustrator and Vtuber and Mint Mama Ayami here.
Welcome!
I'm so sorry my Ayami moving last week.
And my internet so slow, sorry.
So sorry.
I'm really nervous today, but do our best.
Why nervous?
Because too slow internet.
No, I think it's okay, right?
Everybody?
It's okay?
Am I kind of surge buffering for you guys?
If it dies, don't say anything or you'll hurt Ayami Mama's feelings.
My internet, oh yeah.
It's okay.
How about my room?
So small and smelly?
No, smells good.
Today I'm really using whole...
How do you say this?
Favorites, no?
Favorites?
Let's go.
I don't know favorites.
Oh, favorites.
No!
How dare you!
Huh?
Favorite...
Favorite?
Huh?
Favorites.
You don't know favorites?
Favorites?
No, no.
Favorites.
Oh, it's not favorites.
It's not?
I don't know.
Favorites.
I've been using favorites since this morning.
Because like, meat coming.
But three days ago you come...
Yeah.
Yeah, already.
That time I'm using one favorites.
And today, one favorites.
Spend so many money.
Yes.
Oh, sorry.
I pay you.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
Oh, yes.
Hundred dollar.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, thank you.
My mama is very expensive, everybody.
Expensive favorites.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, it's top, top...
Best.
English.
Good luck.
Really cold, Japan.
Yeah, so cold.
Me, too.
But today me, too.
Wearing sandals.
Yeah.
I was wearing sandals today.
I'm really shocked.
It's fine in the afternoon.
No, no, no, no.
I'm so...
She's fit.
I'm really...
Oh, thank you so much, favorites.
Favorites feed.
Thank you so much.
Today, I mean, we met.
And, I mean...
Oh, eh?
Ah?
Your feet?
Huh?
First time I saw your feet.
Oh, there is...
Oh...
How do you say?
New...
Smell?
No, no, new season...
Shoes?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Oh, there is...
Com...
Compa...
How do you say?
Very fashion...
Fashionable.
Fashionable...
No.
Fashionable.
No shoes.
At first.
I didn't know it was socks.
Oh, she didn't realize I was wearing socks.
And she thought I was just wearing, like, really fashionable shoes.
Shoes.
I mean, watching...
No, no, there is socks.
What are you doing?
Too cold.
She thought that it was so cold that I wouldn't be wearing...
Oh, my God.
Why you...
You guys, what are you doing?
Me too...
Too cold winter...
Winter no shoes.
It's Haru.
It's spring.
No, no, no, no, no.
Snowing, but Mint only wearing her socks.
Yeah, really was snowing.
Oh, no.
It was snowing so much.
Two days ago.
Yeah, I'm really got shock.
Oh, Mint.
I understand she's ghost and she cannot...
Feeling the weather?
The snow.
It's true.
Not true.
Very cold.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Please wake up.
You ghost.
Wake up, Mint.
Please wake up.
Fashion is suffering.
Oh, yeah.
I know, yeah.
Yesterday in my stream, I'm told that three days ago, the snowing day, I'm asking to you, Mint, you want my North Face parka?
Mint saying, no.
Mint saying, really, really fast speed, no.
Really bad girl, bad daughter.
So you are saying, it's just how I talk.
Mint just wearing cute thing.
My North Face is...
My brain is ojisan.
Fashion is cute brain ojisan.
Wow, really.
Please buying.
I have.
No.
Yes.
But...
No.
To bring to Japan, so much room in my suitcase.
So...
I don't want to.
Also...
It's colder than I thought it would be.
I think ghosts don't need clothes, isn't it?
Naked is best.
I think naked is best for ghosts.
Next outfit.
Oh...
Ah, there is...
I...
Can I...
No work.
Just naked is...
We already make...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wow.
Can I get some...
Guarantee?
You guys should have seen her face.
Like, was so happy.
She was like, oh.
Really...
This week...
Today...
Now, I'm really happy.
Happy moment.
Wow.
Wow, too cold, but...
Meet...
You know...
This Saturday.
What day?
That day.
Saturday.
That day?
The...
March 8th.
Yeah.
Saturday.
The...
Th...
March 8th is the start of our collaboration cafe.
Ayami family collab cafe 2!
I'm dokidoki.
Me too.
Wakuwaku.
Dokidoki wakuwaku.
Wow.
I'm nervous.
Me too.
Why you nervous?
Because...
Don't look at me!
Why you streaming?
Please look at monitor.
Why you look at me?
Sorry.
Don't look at me.
I'm shy.
Because you're so pretty.
Yeah.
Who?
Who pretty?
You.
Ah, thank you.
She liar.
Everyone.
Don't know why.
She liar.
Wanda.
Everybody say that Ayami mama so cute right now.
Thank you.
Thank you, everyone.
Cute, cute, cute.
Ayami mama so cute.
Mint cute, mint cute.
No, no, no, no.
I know mint cute.
Thank you everyone.
I will buy more favorites.
For mint.
Just my new room.
Stinky.
How do you say that?
Under the sink?
Water.
Bed water.
Yeah.
Smell.
She's having this issue with her new apartment that...
In her sink, like...
From the faucet, it's a weird smell.
Stinky.
Don't worry.
Mint not smelly.
It's okay.
I don't live here.
So scary, but...
Yeah, I'm already nervous Saturday.
Who coming?
Who's coming?
Raise your hand.
Why you raise your hand?
I will go.
Me.
Already?
I'm checking.
Yeah.
I'm checking in front of A-san.
Beside Olaf.
Scary Olaf.
And I'm checking who coming.
Thank you for the superchats.
Thank you.
Many people say they wish they could go.
Yeah, I know.
And everybody who is going...
Buy lots of things.
Buy lots of stuff and then...
Cafe A-san will say...
Wow, they're so popular.
They must have...
Ayami family collaboration set 3.
Oh, yes, yes, yes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The time I really want...
Yeah,
like a whole, whole family.
Yeah.
That is my dream.
I don't want to drink.
Everyone...
No, I will drink.
No, I cannot.
No.
You can.
Yeah.
No, no, no.
Many daughter.
No, I'm too old.
100.
100?
Yeah.
Tired, tired.
Almost dying.
Yes, you guys know.
Mint can draw instead.
You...
Illustration.
Yeah.
Okay, I'll draw the illustration.
Cannot make goods.
Merch.
Mint drawing.
We cannot sell.
We can sell.
We can, yeah.
Yeah, oh.
It will definitely sell.
Oh, that is...
Sorry, omake, omake.
It's like an omake.
It's okay, it's okay.
It'll be like a bonus.
Well, I think everyone happy you're drawing in there.
Yeah.
Have you guys seen the merch?
Everybody wants to know.
What?
Do you know?
Will there be international shipping?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
For the goods.
That's right.
From Asan.
Yes, yes.
That's right.
They'll do it.
They did it before.
Oh, really?
That's right.
But...
It's like buying it at a booth.
Ah.
You can buy it there.
If you buy it at Asan's booth or website, you can send it to your country.
If you use that, you can do it.
I can do it.
So it's kind of like...
It's not booth, but I guess it's Asan's cafe.
It's not booth.
Asan has a website and a booth.
Oh, booth.
Oh, so they do have a booth.
So, they have a site and they also have a booth.
So there will be shipping for...
Yeah.
International goods!
You can get the goods!
Yay!
I'm glad.
Oh, I think everybody was so worried about that.
But I...
Sometimes my dream, I think about...
Oh, me too...
Made cafe in America.
Oh.
I think that is really good for you and for me.
I want open mint-made cafe, but...
America is too big.
Too big, yeah.
If...
If open New York, but...
Can not go in.
Too far, huh?
It's too far.
Yeah, I realize...
Japan, America, not different.
Not so many different, isn't it?
Oh, too big country.
Oh, Europe.
Can I?
May.
Okay, worldwide.
Worldwide.
Worldwide mint in Ayami.
Go, go!
Push, push!
Doki, doki.
So, all the cute goods you see on the side...
In the photos that are...
That is scrolling, you can...
You can buy them too.
Buy them.
I want something to mint.
You...
Normally...
Action...
When you stream time.
What?
You...
You almost dancing.
You almost dancing 20 minutes.
What are you doing?
Last time we have collaboration.
That time is we make food.
And you don't...
You didn't...
I think you cannot dancing.
But...
Now...
No live 2D.
Mint dancing and mint...
Wow, why you so...
Big gesture...
Every time.
Oh my god.
This is top secret.
Your business secret.
Sorry, forgot.
Mint beam.
Forgot, please.
Forget everything.
I'm so sorry.
Everybody forget, please.
Yeah, so sorry.
So sorry.
I'm really cute.
I'm just curious really.
Wow, she...
She's action is really...
Wow.
So...
So embarrassing.
Wow, she...
She almost touching monitor.
Why?
This is not touch panel.
This is just monitor.
Why you touching monitor?
Oh, I'm really...
Don't, don't, don't.
Too cute.
Everybody forget that, please.
Yeah, I know.
She really cute.
Wow.
She burning.
So sorry.
Top secret, I'm saying.
But I know your fans love this...
This story because...
I don't know this kind of story.
That's right.
And...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They don't...
The forget...
Everybody forget, please.
Forget, forget, forget.
Go, go, go, go.
Okay.
We talk about...
What start?
What is good for it?
Maybe...
Closer picture?
Oh, yeah.
That is good.
Yeah.
For everybody who hasn't seen.
So, I'll just make it bigger.
This is...
This is a lottery.
Yeah, lottery.
Lottery.
English, okay.
So...
It's kind of similar to like...
Maybe you guys have seen like Ichiban Kuji kind of style.
Yes, yes, yes.
So, there is different prizes.
Different tiers of prizes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
But everything is cute.
Thank you.
Yeah.
You cute.
No, you cute.
No, no, no, no, no.
Yeah.
So, we cute.
Thank you.
So, for one try, it's 880 yen.
Yeah.
We really signed...
Signed so many.
So many.
This is...
So many...
So many colored papers.
Shikishi.
Shikishi, so many signed.
We...
Almost one hour.
I know, yeah.
It was like one hour of us signing these shikishi.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So...
You know.
There are many of them.
Many, many, many.
Your sign too cute.
No.
No?
Yes.
Why you...
I'm saying something.
Me to say everything no.
Borrowing...
Borrowing my...
Borrow my...
Paka.
No.
Before the stream, I say...
You need water?
You say no.
But you drinking...
You drinking water now?
What are you doing?
You...
Why you saying already no?
You hate me?
No.
Mint hates me.
Mint hates us.
Oh my god.
She hates us.
Yes, we know.
Mint hates us.
Yes.
That is true.
Ayami mama.
Mama doesn't matter.
She hates us.
Yes.
No, shut up everybody.
Shut up.
Go home.
But yeah.
Another picture.
You can see of the...
Hakuriru stand.
Cute.
Look it.
Also...
The...
These...
The badges.
These are actually in a gacha machine.
Yeah.
But...
There is a special thing.
Because...
Some of them are signed.
There are even more signed things.
Right?
Can badges.
So those are also...
There is also winnings with those as well.
So...
You can also maybe get a special signed version.
Yeah.
There is.
We have a picture of it.
This?
This is about 1 out of 3.
This amount is about 1 out of 3.
30% take pictures.
We have more and more signed.
Some are just me and some are both of us.
Yeah.
You really...
It was fun.
Cute.
It was so fun.
Look, look, look.
Winner chicken dinner.
Yeah, I wrote a lot.
Try and get those too.
Okay, everybody.
And then, of course, the Shikishi.
Signed Shikishi.
This is also really...
1 out of 3.
30% Really, really so...
We signed so many.
So many of them.
I'm a little nervous.
I was asking to A-san...
Yeah, just so many...
It's okay to have this many, honestly.
But we really many signed.
We did.
And please get our signed.
Yeah, yeah.
Your signed cute.
The marker was so thick.
It's difficult.
And she...
Mint a little late.
I mean, don't sign.
You are professional.
No, no, no.
I mean, don't sign.
But Mint left almost 5, 5 or 6.
I mean, waiting Mint.
I was a little...
You know, behind.
But she signs these all the time.
My sign is simple.
Me too.
Yes.
But there is lots of these and they are all decorated very much.
So, I think the more I sign, the more I decorate.
So, first it was very simple and then...
Write more.
And then write more.
Purikura, purikura time.
Yes, yes, yes.
Yeah, so...
Everyone, please get it.
Everyone.
What else?
Oh, yes.
Also...
This one.
Yes.
There will be a...
Yes, it's Rakugaki-cho, but please write...
What is this in English?
What?
Like a...
What's it called?
Rolling paper.
What?
It's not rolling paper.
It's like a...
What do you call...
You know when you guys go to a restaurant...
Or no.
Restaurant.
Guestbook.
No, no, no.
Guestbook, guestbook, guestbook.
Yesterday...
Two days ago, I'm asking you...
What is this?
You...
I don't remember.
I couldn't remember.
Me too.
I couldn't remember for two days.
We talk about that.
Sunny side up.
Yeah, yeah.
I couldn't remember.
I did it.
And you did it.
So, read Baka English because I'm asking...
This egg fry...
Egg fries is what kind of egg fry?
This is sunny side up?
Oh, maybe.
But I don't know.
I don't know.
This egg...
Sunny side up?
It's saying that.
I mean...
I'm sorry.
Come here.
I think she came to Japan.
She forgot English.
And Japanese.
What?
She can say zero.
Zero, yeah.
Zero country.
And back to baby.
Oh, that's really cute.
Cute.
Oh,
you guys like this mint?
No, I don't think so.
They're brushing.
You guys are too pure.
Stop it.
Stop it, everybody.
But yeah, please write a comment.
Yeah, please.
Write.
We're checking.
We will write it.
Don't write anything weird.
Can I write something weird?
Mint boobs are small.
That's...
Mint pattern.
It's good.
Okay.
It's okay until mint pattern, right?
Derek, mint pattern.
Mint small boobs.
Mint...
Small.
You're saying too much.
Mint...
Nothing.
Mint has nothing.
Mint...
What else is there?
Mint cute.
Everybody will know, right?
Every page you write.
Mint pattern.
It was fun and delicious.
And mint pattern.
Every comment will be like, I had so much fun.
It was so yummy.
Also, mint is flat.
Finally...
Best part is mint pattern.
Derek is happy.
Please write many things.
Yes, please.
Please, please, please.
Okay.
What else?
What is this?
I wrote this.
We also wrote some other...
What?
Why is mine in the front?
This...
I think it's better to put it in the front.
Really?
Oh my god.
Anyway.
You...
We made also some shikishu that will be hung up on the wall.
I was saying that...
Why did she hide?
No, you hide.
This is your hand.
Yeah, this is my hand.
And I mean...
Kakusu.
What is kakusu?
I mean...
Kakusu your face.
Why?
Because...
Please come and check mint face.
Because mint face is really busu.
She said the face that she drew is ugly.
Yeah.
So she hid it.
Wow, really sorry.
Because too cold day, snowy day.
And my hand is really...
My hand so freeze.
And I cannot draw it.
And mint face is really...
I mean finish my drawing.
Oh my god.
Isn't that normal?
Ah, yeah.
My face is normal.
No, no, no.
Really.
My illustration...
I mean think about...
Oh, illustration job.
No coming.
Really baka drawing.
So sorry.
No, no, no.
It's very cute.
So everybody come and see it.
Please come, Asan.
And please check mint ugly face.
Yeah, top secret.
I cannot see showing internet.
Okay, maybe don't take a picture and upload it.
Then everybody...
It's a secret, okay?
Yeah.
Mine is very simple.
Mosaic, mosaic.
Put a mosaic.
Put a mosaic on it.
Mint face, please mosaic.
Yeah, please censor it.
Okay, everybody.
Thank you.
I believe you guys.
I'm hot.
You're hot?
I want to...
I want to be naked.
Oh, you can.
Go.
Really?
Are you okay?
Okay, okay.
But also...
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
I want to show...
With the standee.
I think this photo is good.
Good?
Yeah.
Standees.
This is real size.
Yeah, it's real size.
Real size.
Real mint and Ayami size.
You can see how small you are next to us.
Because...
I think...
I mean, remember...
Mint?
Mint-chan was standing next to you.
Mint standing beside your standee.
Huh?
Really?
Mint-chan was standing next to you.
And you were a little big.
Me?
Yeah, at first.
And Mint-chan was like, Oh, I'm big.
What should I do?
And she took off her shoes.
She took off her shoes.
And she was like, Oh, we're the same.
And when she took off her shoes, I was like, Oh, that's it.
Your shoes are 30cm.
30cm.
Mint shoes.
30cm higher.
I was standing next to my standee at first.
She was like, Oh, the mint is actually taller than it.
Than the standee.
And then I took off my shoes because they're kind of platforms.
And she was like, She's actually the same size.
That's good.
I'm really shocked.
Wow, mint.
I want that shoes.
Let's go get some.
Yeah, I'm really cute and...
Thick.
Sometimes, some dangerous time, we can using the shoes.
Some dangerous time.
Weapon.
We can using weapon.
It's not that dangerous.
I think it's...
I think this is really good because this time, the print is really good.
I'm really happy.
It looks so good.
Happy.
Everybody take lots of photos with it.
Okay.
You're so cute.
Oh, thank you.
I'm drawing.
But this time, I'm really...
This time, really difficult.
When I drawing Mint and Ayami, collaboration, cafe, illustrations, that time...
Most difficult part is...
I think...
My image.
Mint.
My image of Mint and...
How can I say?
My fan's image of Mint.
I think it's a little different.
I wanted to draw Mint that my fan said it's cute.
I want Mint's fan see my illustration and they are happy.
But when I drawing time, just to focus...
Love Mint.
I cannot think of sometimes your fans.
Just think about my feeling.
My feeling.
Love Mint.
I love you.
And drawing hard.
Finish illustration.
I'm a little...
I mean...
How can I say?
Reflection.
How can I say in English?
I mean...
I'm like that.
After finishing work, I have to draw like this again.
Oh, like...
How can I say?
English.
Please look it up.
I mean...
I mean more...
Drawing...
For fans...
Fans...
English.
Okay, so...
Basically, when she's drawing sometimes, she's just like...
She's not really thinking of your perception...
Your opinions.
She's thinking like...
I want to...
I just am thinking of drawing how much I love Mint.
Yeah.
And so...
And so, I guess...
How is it different though?
But don't you...
She doesn't want to just draw the Mint that she loves, but also the one that everybody loves.
But...
Well,
sometimes I'm drawing ugly Mint.
But that is my drawing.
And I like my drawing.
There's no ugly.
No, no, no.
Sometimes, sometimes.
I mean really...
So many times...
Drawing again...
Surgery.
Mint face surgery.
Oh, I'm getting plastic surgery.
Plastic surgery Mint.
Mint more...
Cute...
Cute eyes Mint.
I mean make Mint every time.
That's funny.
Yeah, she says that she has to like...
Reflect on it.
Kind of like...
She has to really like...
Kind of...
Look back on it.
Be like...
This is so cute.
Right, everybody?
You think the...
The illustrations...
Oh, the illustrations for the cafe are so cute.
Right?
Look, look.
But there is a twin tail.
Oh, you can see here.
Twin tail.
Kawaii.
Really kawaii.
Really.
Thank you.
Thank you, Celia-san.
Thank you, Celia-mama.
Celia-papa.
Celia-papa is really a genius.
Yes, a genius.
And...
Oh, this too.
Another preview of some of the food.
Which one could be it?
This is really delicious.
This is...
Yeah, this is actually so delicious, you guys.
Really yummy.
Really, really.
It's actually so yummy.
Wow, this is really fantastic.
I really like this.
This is my special omurice.
I will make you curse though, so...
They don't know this love.
No, no, no.
Wow.
A little spoil.
Okay.
The first time Mint and I made a food idea, Mint sent me this omurice and compote.
She drew it.
At that time, I first saw that picture.
I mean...
First, my opinion...
A little...
Disgusting.
Because it's not yellow.
Almost everything is white.
It's yellow.
No, no.
Omurice is yellow, but that compote is almost gray.
Gray color, not yellow.
I'm sorry.
I mean, first time...
Check that image.
I'm really shocked.
Got shocked, but...
I cannot say because...
She really thinks about menu and she loves...
You should say!
But...
I mean, never...
I have been...
I've never eaten it.
She's never tried it before.
Oh, yeah.
This omurice with compote.
I cannot say anything.
And I'm really nervous.
Before the real food...
I mean, met real food.
Before the...
But finally, finally...
Asa made this.
And I'm...
Wow!
This is it!
What?
This is really...
Hot, hot.
Really...
Really good.
Wow, amazing.
Wow.
Thank you, Asa.
I'm so sorry.
First time I saw...
Your laugh and think about that.
It's okay.
I really want to...
Showing that...
The laugh.
It's my color.
I didn't...
I didn't choose yellow because...
The omurice is yellow.
Only yellow.
That is really...
White and gray.
What did you do?
Someone threw up?
Omurice.
Oh, wow.
This is...
What is this?
If she write...
The right...
Text...
That...
Comportage.
But...
I cannot believe.
Yeah.
I even wrote that it's corn soup.
But she...
But I cannot...
I cannot believe.
Wow, this color is not corn soup.
What is this?
It's corn soup.
No.
But finally...
Make...
Making Asa...
Really good...
Coloring.
Color and...
Yummy things.
It's really good and it's big.
Big, big.
Really big for you.
It's really big size.
Please introduce my drawing.
What is this?
That...
Food sheet.
This?
Yeah.
So...
Say that.
Say it.
I got a little busy.
And...
She broke me again.
No.
Wow.
She broke me again.
I think she...
Block this code.
And...
She line...
Block one day.
No, no, no.
Just one day.
Block again.
She was sending me the stuff to check.
The...
Sample food.
That they first created.
And...
I said it's good.
But...
It's because...
She had to draw the...
The...
So...
But it looks exactly like...
The original I drew.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Because I mean...
Oh, trace?
Yeah.
You're drawing to trace.
Trace.
Me to drawing.
Just I mean drawing heart.
She had to trace my drawing.
Please don't block me.
Please.
One year...
One time she...
Block me.
I never blocked you.
Why you don't send message?
You checking message?
No, I think you block...
Block everywhere.
Block brand.
I think she block X too.
Blocked every...
Blocked on Twitter.
Blocked on X.
Just one week ago you...
Unlock block.
Because she coming Japan.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
We are okay.
We are Nakayoshi.
Nakayoshi.
Yeah, Nakayoshi.
We have Nakayoshi parfait.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Scary, scary.
And if for everybody...
If you buy over 5,000...
Yeah.
5,000 yen.
5,000.
5,000 yen worth of goods you can...
Be entered into a...
Lottery...
To get a signature.
Yeah, from Ayami Mama.
Yeah.
Ah,
okay, okay.
So, if you win also...
You can also contact...
Because you might not be, you know, in the...
In Japan anymore when the signing event happens.
You can still contact...
The cafe.
And they will still be able to send it to you.
So,
this is if you get over 5,000 yen worth of stuff.
And then it's a lottery.
But everybody will want a beautiful signature from Ayami Mama, yeah.
Not beautiful.
It's next Thursday.
Next Thursday.
Thursday, Saturday.
Thursday, Lottery.
Oh, there's a...
Lottery...
And Saturday...
Sign autograph session.
Oh, just kidding.
It's Saturday.
I'm sorry.
Just kidding.
What are you saying?
Wow, yeah.
That's famous English.
Oh, wow, really?
Everywhere can using?
Yeah, yeah.
Just kidding.
It's not a lie.
It's not a mistake.
Just kidding.
Ah, okay, okay.
I understand.
Okay.
You broke me again.
Ah, just kidding.
Just kidding.
Okay, okay.
Good English.
Right, everybody?
Okay, okay.
Did you guys see the map that I drew?
Yeah.
Really good drawing.
I drew this on the train going back from Akihabara.
And I drew it on my phone.
So, everybody...
Really sweet, but really snowing.
I want to go back.
Me too, using car.
But she...
No, I want to take video.
Too many snow, too cold.
Yeah, it's okay.
Akihabara's snowing is really good.
Wow, she really, really...
Really otaku.
Wow, best otaku.
Yeah, she offered me a ride, but I was like, but I want to take a video.
Really sweet.
A-san.
Gaffer A-san want to...
Oh, yeah, yeah.
They wanted to make sure that you guys know that it's north of Akiba under the train tracks.
Sorry, my original picture was upside down.
But it's north.
North!
North of Akiba.
A-san is north.
North.
But it's under the train tracks.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Google, Google!
Yeah, you can Google, you'll be fine.
Yeah, Google is okay.
Google is okay.
You can find...
Olaf.
Scary Olaf.
You correct...
Correct way, you can find this.
Okay, A-san.
Google scary Olaf.
Searching scary Olaf.
No, no, no, no.
Please search Gaffer A-san and please call.
I want to say that starting time, gaffer, because...
Okay,
so the days, the openings of each of the cafe are a little different.
So on a weekday, it's from 3pm.
But you can go.
3pm and then, but on the weekends, it's from 11am.
Yeah, so...
Please check time.
Just don't go at like 9am.
You won't.
You can't be there unless you're lining up.
Yeah, don't be, don't catch a cold.
Yeah.
Before the stream, we studied English time.
I mean, I want to say, because my cat Poo caught a cold.
But I mean, I want to say to Mint, Poo catch a cold.
Catch cold, got cold.
Something, something cold, Mint say.
Caught, because the pest, pest thing, caught a cold.
Okay, English.
Mama tensai.
Mama tensai!
English.
She remember.
This is really simple.
She liar, because she cannot say English.
Yes, true.
She teaching English?
It's true.
Okay, you're really really good teaching, because I understand.
But that time, nobody learns anything.
And when I teach them, they don't remember.
Just talking.
I'm really surprised.
Wow, wow, amazing.
Yes, yes, yes.
Please check map.
Please check the map.
Shall we show the video?
Yes.
Is the sound okay?
Is the sound loud?
Is it okay?
I guess we'll check it.
So we have a little preview to show you guys.
Of some stuff that we recorded.
That will be playing inside the cafe.
And we will play it and tell us if the audio is okay.
Okay.
Push.
We're also going to be talking.
First is loading.
Opening.
Can you guys hear this?
Yes.
This BGM.
This?
Up.
Oh, snack.
Okay.
It's good?
You can hear it?
Okay, so this is like the loading video.
I'm just going to skip through it.
Obviously...
It's really long.
Two minutes.
Opening, two minutes.
Skip, please.
Okay, we'll skip.
Thank you.
Good timing.
Oh, you died.
Oh, need to die, okay.
Oh my god.
You can see the drinks, but my drink is messed up.
Oh yeah, so you can see...
That is syrup.
Syrup?
Oh, yeah.
It's caramel latte.
Yeah.
Yeah, caramel.
She first time drink no syrup.
She push push syrup and she messed up my illustration.
Really bad daughter.
Sorry, sorry.
Whatever, what does it look before?
Yeah.
See?
What a kawaii.
She alive.
No.
Still dead.
Sorry.
She looks like alive.
Not ectoplasm.
Oh, yes.
Of course, melon soda is really good color for mint, but I'm really...
You cannot drink.
No.
Yeah, but she make this menu.
And I'm a little confused.
But people can drink.
Not me.
It's okay.
This time drink I'm everything.
I'm drink everything.
So, yeah.
It comes with udon.
Yeah.
Udon with... you can get the little cake and the dango and udon.
So it's a little set.
My favorite.
Oh, really?
What's next?
Oh!
I love, love, love.
This is really...
You can't hear it.
I'm talking?
Yeah.
I'm talking.
She doesn't have headphones on, so she can't hear.
But I can hear it.
We're talking about the...
The mint flavor.
This is not strong mint, really.
No, it's not really strong mint.
And really cute.
The mint color and chocolate.
It's more milky flavor than mint.
So if you don't like... even if you don't like mint, maybe you should still try it.
Yeah, please.
Yeah.
And this...
Your drink.
Yeah, my drink.
Something something.
Fuwa Fuwa.
Fuwa Fuwa love potion.
This is lemon and grapefruit.
And a little peach.
A little peach.
And this is really sweet and lovely and sexy taste.
Please try it!
It was delicious.
Right?
Yeah, but what the ame?
Yeah, it's like a cocktail, but it has no alcohol in it.
Ah, that's a mocktail.
Ah, mocktail.
Yeah, so it's like a cocktail, but it's a mocktail.
It has no alcohol in it.
Cotton candy.
But you can still get litty.
Got so many sugar.
You can.
Yeah, you'll get drunk off sugar.
Dine.
No.
Yeah, so try it.
Last drop of mint.
You made a mess.
Shut up!
The worst!
No!
There it is.
You ate it, but it's not cute.
I want to show you the...
Cute?
Yeah, that's good.
Not messed up.
This is Napolitan.
I like Napolitan.
Some sauces.
Guys, is this sunny side up?
Yeah, this is sunny side up.
This is sunny side up egg.
This is sunny side up, correct?
I think, right?
Yes?
No?
Scary.
Yeah, scary.
So yummy.
Napolitan is a little different from spaghetti.
Because it's...
Ketchup.
Ketchup taste.
Ketchup and sausage taste.
But it's yummy.
Good for health.
I don't think so.
Shut up!
Don't bother my selling.
Don't bother my business, okay?
Shut up, meat.
This is my business, okay?
Please try this.
Please.
It's good for your health.
She's 100 years old, she knows.
Yeah, I think this is really good for health.
Because of pi-mang.
And belly...
The green...
Green pepper.
Pepper.
And tomato.
How you know more English than me?
I'm good English.
Today.
Just today.
Really good today.
And...
I think this is really good healthy food, please.
Try this.
Yeah, try it.
Try it.
And then you saw my omurice.
Really good.
That's so pretty.
Yeah.
My drawing is really good.
This was delicious.
This is really yummy.
Yeah.
My doriya...
Ura...
Ura-meshiya.
Doriya-meshiya.
This is so good.
It's got like tomatoes and sweet potato and broccoli and ham.
And...
Bacon, bacon.
Bacon, just kidding.
Rice.
Wow.
Just kidding.
Using...
Okay, okay.
I like this.
Okay, I understand.
Studying English, okay?
Okay, okay.
What's the...
Hanpen.
Hanpen, it's like a fish cake.
Yeah, but almost no taste.
Yeah, yeah.
It really doesn't have a taste.
It's kind of like bread almost.
Yeah, almost bread and less calorie.
That is real healthy food.
Yeah, see?
I made something really healthy with lots of vegetables.
Yeah.
Fish cake.
Hanpen.
It's Hanpen.
There is rice underneath.
The cream sauce inside is really rich and creamy.
Rich and creamy cream sauce.
The sauce was really delicious.
Really good sauce and hot.
Really hot.
I'm hungry.
The sauce was so good.
The cheese was so good.
I think out of everything, I would want to eat this again.
Oh, no.
I want to eat this again.
Yeah.
I want to eat it.
No, no, no.
Don't bother my business.
Napolitan.
Napolitan, try Napolitan.
This is really yummy.
Yeah, hot, hot, hot and yummy.
Yeah.
Fish head.
Healthy food.
This is really healthy.
It's stringy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Nice.
Sorry, sorry.
I pressed the wrong button.
Hey, hey, hey, Mint.
Seriously, seriously.
Hey, Mint.
You've been streaming for a few years?
I think you are a professional VTuber.
I'm professional.
Oh, yeah.
This is a small mistake.
Okay, dessert.
We make together dessert.
This is pancake.
Pancake.
But hot cake.
Souffle hot cake.
It's like different from a pancake.
Souffle.
Souffle?
Oh, it's like a souffle?
Souffle.
English?
Yeah, French.
French?
Mint Phantom.
Yeah, I like Mint Phantom and souffle cake.
This is really fluffy.
Fluffy?
Fluffy.
Fluffy Oppa.
Oh, yes, yes, yes.
Yeah, I like fluffy.
And the cat face, Riff's face is make cream cheese.
Yeah, the cream cheese.
Yeah, and maple syrup.
And fluffy bread.
Yeah.
And really good taste.
It's so good.
Overweight cat thing.
Minna wakaru.
Getting overweight.
Sorry.
Sorry guys.
But this is so lovely one plate because strawberry is pink and mint chocolate is green as our color.
Color.
Yeah, and this is really, I think...
The whipped cream.
Like Fuji.
Fuji-san.
That pile of whipped cream is only whipped cream.
Yeah, inside every, no empty place.
Oh, yeah.
All whipped cream.
You guys almost dying, I think.
Maybe.
Real sugar.
Yeah.
But I think this you can eat and walk around Akihabara.
It's good.
Yeah.
No dying, don't worry.
Yeah, don't worry.
Don't worry.
All cream is so delicious.
It's okay, it's okay.
It was delicious, right?
Ice cream.
Strawberry ice cream was really delicious.
Strawberry ice cream is really...
It was really like...
Strong...
Ichigo.
Strong strawberry taste.
Strong ichigo.
Wow, she's English is something like...
Yeah.
She forget everything.
Okay.
Next.
She's eating.
She's still eating.
Your glove is okay.
It's okay.
Your glove...
I don't know your glove is okay or not.
It's okay.
Ta-da.
This is the Nakayoshi parfait.
It's not Nakayoshi.
It's Nakayoshi.
Good, really.
Wow, this...
This is really good.
Inside matcha.
Yeah.
Green tea cream is...
Yeah, it's like...
Adult taste.
Do we have that?
I think so.
It's more like...
Full refined palate.
Mature taste?
Maybe, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Really good taste.
Not too much...
Sweet.
This is really...
Bittersweet.
So,
yeah.
It's very...
Yeah, it's not super duper sweet.
It's like...
My gloves are so ugly.
Your glove!
Don't...
Everybody don't laugh at them, okay?
Your glove!
But look at...
And also, I thought it might be matcha ice cream.
But it's actually a matcha cream.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But matcha ice cream small...
And matcha cream mix, mix, mix.
And inside.
So, yeah.
It's really nice.
I'm getting hungry.
I'm starving.
It looks yummy.
Your glove.
They keep me warm.
It's okay.
Cute.
Yeah, yeah.
Oishi.
And strawberries in there, too.
And the cookie.
And look, the whipped cream has the face.
It's like a ghost.
Yes.
It looks like a ghost, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't laugh at my dumb hole.
Oh my god.
It's so I can use my phone.
You guys, what are you doing?
Please buy some gloves for me.
It's like a...
The holes are on purpose.
It's so that you can use it.
You can put your finger out.
No, no, this...
That is just a whore.
No, no, no, no.
She's using so many.
She...
No, she...
She's poor.
Soy pobre.
I'm not poor.
She's poor and...
No.
Oh, really...
Really...
Oh, mint.
Mint.
Oh, yeah.
Took the grass off.
Yeah, grass.
Oh, you can eat it.
Oh, never mind.
Just kidding.
So we ate that.
Wow.
It was good.
Is that everything?
OK.
Ending.
She will go.
So go and eat everything everybody.
I will be there.
Looks delicious.
Good.
It is delicious.
What is this?
That's right.
Did you get it?
The camera...
The camera is behind you.
Behind?
The camera...
This?
We have a little thing today.
Try it.
It didn't come out.
You can't do it.
Hold on.
We have maybe a little hand camera action real quick.
One more time.
One more time, OK.
OK.
Yeah, we have something we want to try.
Sorry.
You guys, I'm scared.
I'm scared.
Hold on.
Was it this?
No.
The camera...
The shape of the camera...
Sorry, I said it in English.
You can say it in English.
You can't see it.
Why?
This.
OK.
Sorry.
Sorry everybody.
We had it set up and then I think it reset.
Yeah, sorry.
Music.
BGM.
Ah, BGM.
Oh, snack time.
OK.
Thank you.
I'm embarrassed.
I put my gloves on too much earlier.
Let's try not to show your hands.
Yes, please.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh my god.
It's big.
Ah.
Resetting.
Hello everybody.
Please hold.
Oh, double audio.
Yes, yes, yes.
Because...
Video capture.
There.
Everyone is fast.
Right?
Color.
Ah, English.
Yes, yes, yes.
Ah, it's not this.
It's not this.
Color.
Some.
Yes.
Yes, yes.
Yes, yes, yes.
Oh, wait.
Can I try?
Oh, yeah.
Gray.
Gray hand.
With this...
Where is gray hand?
Copy.
What do you copy?
Previous settings.
Ah, ah.
And with this...
Oh, paste.
Was it this?
Your settings.
This is my settings.
I copied and pasted the same settings that she had from earlier.
And she's like, was this actually it?
This way.
Okay, this way.
I want to copy.
Okay, guys.
Are you okay?
I'm okay.
Mint-chan has never tried this before.
I heard Mint-chan never tried this.
One more time?
Okay.
Just one time?
Oh, oh.
She says, I've never tried this before.
Yeah.
I've never tried this before, you guys.
I'm scared!
Are you okay?
I think she...
Tonight, she...
She finally hate Japan.
Everyone knows.
Everybody knows.
How do you guys know?
She...
It's so big.
You know what it is?
You know?
I don't know.
Oh, yeah.
Don't worry, I'm teaching you.
Okay.
I will teach you.
Okay, this is...
Natto.
This is natto.
You know natto?
No, no?
No, no, I don't know natto.
Okay, don't worry.
I can teach you.
Okay, okay, okay.
Natto is...
Kusa bean.
It's a sticky bean.
English.
Fermented beans.
You know what is this?
This is kusa.
It's a straw.
This is real natto, everyone.
This is real natto.
Today, Mint-chan...
Today, I mean...
Go go Shinjuku.
I'm really tired.
I'm really tired because hikikomori.
But, I mean, really.
Be brave.
Really.
Okay.
I'll be brave.
Yeah, be brave, Ayami.
Be brave, Ayami.
Because I'm go Shinjuku and I mean...
Went Isetan department store.
You know Isetan?
Isetan?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, really big department store and I'm searching natto.
Where is natto?
Excuse me.
Please, traditional natto.
I'm searching traditional natto and I mean...
Buying this.
Kusa.
I can smell it from here.
I think Mint is crying.
I'm crying.
I think she loves this.
Kusa.
You guys are so scared.
I'm so scared.
I've never tried it before.
No, no, no, no.
It's okay.
This is really...
Meme.
It's okay.
They're coming.
She come in Japan and she brain melt, I think.
This is wara natto.
Kome no...
Kome no kusa.
It's like a...
Rice.
It's rice grass.
Yeah.
And this is...
Focus, please.
Natto.
Wow.
But...
It's so smelly.
It smells so bad.
This is first time.
Me too.
Oh, really?
I always...
But this is by Isetan department store.
It's fancy.
Yeah, I have chopstick.
Do we?
You already throw up?
Okay, okay.
First, I may eat.
Tell me.
Don't worry, don't worry, everyone.
This is not...
It smells so bad.
Your feet smell.
This is your feet.
No, no, no.
This is your armpit.
It really does smell like feet.
This is your armpit smell.
Oh, my God.
It smells so bad.
Is it bad?
No.
No?
Delicious.
Oh, no, I don't believe.
I don't believe it.
This is amazing.
She's putting soy sauce on it.
Because...
First time people need some soy sauce.
Okay, okay.
Oh, this is yummy.
This is...
If she will not do...
No!
When I talk time...
She can smell it.
I'm Kusa.
That's too much.
Just one.
Are you gonna feed it to me?
Yeah.
Because this is a little scary.
It's scary.
I'm scared.
This is for me.
Just one.
Just one for me.
Okay.
You can do it.
It's not bad.
Oh, no.
Drink is okay.
Just drink...
Just eat time is okay, but...
Open...
Open mouth...
Kusa.
It was the aftertaste.
Not taste.
This is just smell, isn't it?
No, no, no.
Taste.
Maybe it's mix.
Because I smell bad.
Because it smells bad and...
Also, maybe...
This is yummy.
If you like Japan, you must eat this.
No?
You hate Japan?
Already?
I hate Japan.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
This
is for you.
Yeah, this is from Isetan.
I want to wash...
I mean...
Prepare...
Wash your mouth things.
Not...
What is that?
The thing to do that.
Mouthwash?
Mouth...
Mouthwash.
It's not bath.
I mean prepare this for you mean.
It looks expensive.
Oh my god.
Natto after Ichigo is good.
Yeah, palate cleanser.
You guys check in.
Good, good.
Check in.
The price?
Focus.
I mean...
Spending money buying fabric and buying Ichigo.
Wow, just one.
Just one piece?
One piece is just...
It's almost...
It's like 8 dollars for one.
Just one.
This is cheap thing in there.
Really?
This is really cheap.
Expensive thing is...
3,000 yen.
3,000 yen?
Yeah.
For one.
Just one.
For one?
It's expensive.
Really expensive but...
I mean can buy this for mint.
Thank you everybody for fanbox.
Thank you everyone for fanbox.
Thank you.
Mint-chan is also in there.
Mint-chan, thank you.
Yes, yes.
I'm also a fanbox member.
I mean give to me too.
It's so big.
This is for you.
Share?
No.
This is just one.
For you.
Are you sure?
Because I have no money.
I can buy just one.
This is my life.
Don't worry everyone.
I'm still alive.
Please try this.
Here everybody.
I'll compare to my hand.
You can see the size.
Can I show it?
It's fine.
Your hand is so small.
It smells good.
It smells so good.
It smells like natto.
Natto smell.
The natto smell is gone.
Now it's Ichigo smell.
Natto smell.
It's really big.
Yummy, yummy.
She left and she started coughing.
Probably because of the smell of the natto.
Okay.
Itadakimasu.
It tastes like a strawberry.
So yummy.
Where did she go?
I'm all by myself now.
It's delicious.
It's gone.
She put it in the fridge.
She put the natto in the fridge.
Yeah, because...
That is too...
Expensive.
It's very high quality.
What are you showing this?
Why are you showing this?
Your...
You're erotic.
No!
How is this not erotic?
Everyone look at this and imagine something.
What?
Something weird things.
What things are you imagining everybody?
Yeah, I know.
Everyone imagine something.
Isn't it?
No.
No, yes.
I know you guys.
You guys think about something, something.
I know.
I don't think so.
Okay.
I want to share.
Indirect kiss?
Yeah.
Can I?
Can I everyone?
You...
You clean?
Yeah.
No, I just ate natto.
You eat...
Natto.
I ate natto.
You eat natto.
I'm healthy.
Healthy?
No, you kusa.
You kusa.
You eat natto already.
Itadakimasu.
Everyone is jealous, right?
No, no, no.
I think you guys jealous.
They don't care.
They're jealous because they want to eat strawberry.
Not indirect kiss?
No, no, no.
Itadakimasu.
Ah.
It's good.
It's good, right?
What is this?
It's good.
Eh?
No way.
What is this?
It's good.
Right?
It's really...
Refreshing?
It's not sour.
It's sweet.
It's just a sweetie.
It's like a...
Yeah, very...
Not very sour.
It's very like...
That...
She ate it all.
Yummy.
I ate 900 yen.
Because it's 100 yen.
Just 100 yen eat meat.
900 yen.
Yeah, I am sorry.
Yeah, the thing was 1000 yen.
No, this is for you.
Only for you.
Yay, competition.
Yeah, she ate...
Of the 1000 yen that the strawberry cost, she ate 900 yen and I had 100 yen.
So sorry, you guys.
Oh my god.
Was it worth?
It was good.
With this color...
The price...
But...
Check price and...
Brain...
How should I say it?
I feel like it's good.
But it's good.
Right?
It's good.
The texture is also good.
It's crispy.
It's good.
I'm sorry I ate it all.
I will eat natto later.
After stream, we share natto again.
I don't come back to Japan.
I mean, put in Mint's bag.
Natto.
And she...
Bag she saw that time train.
Kusa.
Subway, everyone.
What's smell?
Her feet.
Kusa.
So sorry.
Natto.
I did my best.
How was it?
You don't want to eat it again?
Never try again?
Maybe cheap.
Maybe inexpensive.
One.
Maybe.
Maybe natto roll.
Natto roll is fine.
I will make it now.
I can make natto roll.
No.
Stop saying feet.
Yes, so...
So you really don't come back?
Never come again?
I don't think about it.
Oh yeah, sorry.
I mean, kill every natto in Japan.
Don't worry.
Please come again.
And everybody go to the cafe, there is no natto.
So it smells good in there.
Yeah, really good.
The cola smell is good too.
Please using everywhere and eat and buy everything.
And please take picture and take video.
And please share on Twitter X.
Use the hashtags.
They are on Twitter, so use them.
Okay.
I'm really happy because mint...
This time we... third time we meet... met.
I'm really happy.
I mean, met so many mint and...
Mint trying natto.
Third time this trip, everybody.
Not third time in total.
And I'm really happy I can make collaboration cafe with mint.
That is really my pleasure.
I love mint and I love you guys.
Mint hates us, yes.
But I love you, don't worry.
We... I think mint and Ayami make funny things more...
More event or something something.
And please support Ayami and mint.
Please.
Push, push Ayami and mint.
Thank you.
Push, please.
Thank you everybody for coming to watch the stream.
Maybe some of you are not in Japan.
But thanks for watching anyway.
And hopefully next time we can do another collaboration cafe together.
And everybody else will be able to come again.
Yes.
Thank you.
Okay, we're gonna go.
Go home.
I have to go home.
You go home?
Oh, I'm lonely.
Oh, you have push on.
No, no, no.
Okay, never.
Okay, I spend the night.
Okay guys, please.
I forgot.
Forgot was because I'm 100.
I just want to say...
Waiting mint a little longer.
Mint back.
I think.
She hates Japan too.
Mint back soon, don't worry.
Yeah, I'll be home soon.
Thank you.
Guys, I'll get the karaoke stream back up.
But yeah, for now...
Hai.
Hai, okay.
Aisatsu suru no?
Maybe, what's Ayami do?
Okay.
Hai.
Okay, thank you everybody.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Sorry 100 years brain fog, brain fog.
She's 100 years everybody.
Because I'm hungry.
I want more natto.
Okay, one more, one more please.
One more, one more.
One, two...
Otsu Ayamito!
Bye bye!